التغييرات التي احدثتها حرب اوكرانيا في
اوروبا ابديه واكثر عمقا من اي حدث اخر
مدن نهايه الحرب البارده عام 1989 صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز اكدت ان الحرب اسفرت عن
زعزعه غير مسبوقه للعقيده السياسيه في بعض
البلدان كالمانيا حيث ازاحت عقليه السلام
والحياد وافسحت الطريقه امام ادراك ضروره
القوه العسكريه لتحقيق اهداف امنيه
واستراتيجيه واعاده الاعتبار لجيوش مهمله
منذ عقودا هذا وبدات الحرب الاوكرانيه
اوهام اوروبا بشان سياسه التواصل المعتاد
مع روسيا فهي ازاله الاقنعه وفق قول
الرئيس الفنلندي سوليني نينسو
ووصفتي الصحيفه الامريكيه لفتره الحاليه
بعصر اعاده الترتيب مضيفه انه لا عود
للوراء حتى بعد انتهاء الحرب فدول خرجت عن
حيادها ومدت اوكرانيا بالمساعدات العسكريه
واخرى اضطرت للتكيف مع قطع امدادات النفط
والغاز الروسي
[موسيقى]